hi I'm Eric Voss and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe revealed a new
game-changer for the Avengers in the
form of the Skrull the race of alien
shapeshifters who infiltrate the ranks
of the US government by impersonating
shield agents in Captain Marvel but if
you read the Marvel comics you know that
the Skrull are potentially a much bigger
deal than they appear to be in the
capital Marvel movie because in the
Secret Invasion storyline a number of
known Marvel heroes are actually scroll
imposters the whole time the whole time
ball time now in Captain Marvel and
spoiler warning if you haven't seen the
movie yet or if you're worried that I
might accidentally break something that
happens in the future of marble in this
movie the scroller actually lists bad
and we thought they'd be they are not
the evil imposters hell-bent on taking
over our planet they're actually just
weari refugees looking for a new home
world away from the real bad guys the
imperialists Creed it looks as though
they don't even arrive to Earth until
the events of this film while looking
for Marvel's hidden lab in Earth's orbit
four of the scroll washed up on the
beach their leader Talos his science guy
another one who impersonates Coulson
during the chase and a fourth scroll
whom Carol chases on the train aka the
one who got away
Talos reunites with his family in the
end science guy gets killed by Yann
raagh scroll son dies in the car crash
and get sawed top seed but squirrel
number four remains a mystery could
scroll number four have gone on to
impersonate a character who we've known
all this time the whole time or thought
that we've known the whole time the
whole time could scroll number four ever
join up with another independent group
of scroll on earth somewhere an
extremist terrorist group kind of like
the squirrels version of Ronin who
unlike the friendlier Talos group does
seek to subvert humanity in a secret
invasion type plot this lingering
mystery has launched a new investigation
because in my mind you can't trust
anyone
I plan to scrutinize each MCU figure one
by one in a new series that we're
calling scroll surge
and for this first scroll search let's
direct our eye to the man who has taught
us the most about who and who not to
trust Nick Fury he got close to the most
others to the scroll during the events
of Captain Marvel he's been around
forever and some of his choices in
retrospect seem a little curious so is
Nicholas Joseph Fury a scroll King
number 1 potentially the biggest
evidence for fury perhaps being a scroll
is this leaked concept art for Captain
Marvel showing a scroll turning into
Nick Fury a frame-by-frame transition
kinda like an Animorph so did we get him
is this scroll search over we're going
home now of course these are not
storyboards and doesn't confirm anything
all concept art for movies is merely
drawn up by movie artists in early
developmental stages to help the
filmmakers get a sense of what the movie
could look like other characters movie
end up getting impersonated by a scroll
so it makes sense that they would want
to consider what it would look like if
it happened to fury though it is
interesting that the version of fury
that the scroll turns into in this
concept art is the modern one not the
90s look from Captain Marvel which some
are suggesting could mean they wanted to
consider fury in the present day
continuing to be a scroll in disguise
then again this art could have been
drawn up so early in the process that
the crew hadn't even walked down what
nineties fury would look like so they
use a more modern look of fury that they
had on file let's move on to clue number
two why didn't Fury page Captain Marvel
for past emergencies it's a question
that we've been wondering about since
infinity war like why did fury wait for
the apocalyptic attack of Thanos to ring
her up and not the events that seemed
just as dire at the time the Chitauri
invasion Hydra with the helicarrier's
Ultron the Dark Dimension opening up
mysterious alien goo nearly swallowing
up Missouri all of these events if some
heroes somewhere didn't eke out a win
would have ended life on Earth as fury
knew it now I just assume the Captain
Marvel movie would address this question
all we got was a quick scene of Carol
handing fury back the pager insane only
for emergencies or disappeared in space
with the other scroll so what theory
were those other near disasters not
emergencies the simple answer though
it's not perfect is that maybe Fury
trusted the Avengers to handle those
other problems on their own kind of like
a kids basketball coach Bradley
the kids to win the game on their own
even though his best friend is Air Bud
and he could get that Golden Retriever
to show up and drop buckets all over
these dopes but that still wouldn't make
sense for that goo in Missouri fury
wouldn't have known what the hell was
going on there since it was an effect of
the guardians of the galaxy's battle
with ego elsewhere across the universe
of course this emergency didn't last
that long before it mysteriously stopped
but you gotta imagine that fury would
have had a similar reaction time that he
had to face his snap and probably would
have considered whipping out that pager
but the explanation that we're getting
that is that fury could have actually
been a scroll that at some point after
the events of Captain Marvel missing
scroll number four shows up copies fury
and then takes his place and then over
the years take steps to weaken earth
allow these emergencies to happen all to
avoid another imperialist empire like
the Kree from evolving and posing a
threat to his scroll race but Fury's
longtime relationship with shield brings
us to another interesting exchange
between Fury and cap and Winter Soldier
last time I trusted someone I lost you
no no no no not that one but thank you
for showing it I'm talking about this
one my wife kicked me out didn't know
you were married a lot of things you
don't know about me uh-huh
and how does the scene end
just yeah that's right clue number three
fury totally died after taking three
shots through the chest
fury flatlined on the operating table
with cap and black widow pretty sharp
eyed soldiers who have been around their
fair share of corpses convinced of his
death of course later in the movie his
death was revealed to have been faked
with fury saying he's slow to start
using tetrodotoxin be a serum developed
by Bruce Banner to slow the heart rate
to one beat per minute yeah okay I guess
we're meant to believe this because
notice the doctor who's caring for fury
it's the same surgeon who called his
death in the hospital implying that this
was all staged and that this surgeon and
his whole team probably several other
members of the hospital staff had all
were Hurst faking Fury's death and
totally kept their cool while being
closely watched by two Avengers and this
doctor should stick out to you because
this is a cameo by Joe freaking Russo
the co-director of Winter Soldier Civil
War infinity war and end game one of the
three masterminds keeping all the
secrets of the future of Marvel at this
moment if there is a deeper conspiracy
here of course this dude is gonna be
present to help smooth it over imagine a
scenario we're missing scroll number
four does end up shape-shifting into
fury but then it doesn't kill the
original fury or keep him tied up
somewhere but that these two Furies end
up working in tandem
remember this scroll team is one that
fury into the pain friendly with at the
end of Captain Marvel and how many times
this fury suggested to keep eyes and
ears open everywhere what better way to
do that than to have two of him so let's
say the death of Nick Fury was exactly
what it looked like the death of Nick
Fury this whole dr. Russo tetrodotoxin
explanation is just crazy enough to be a
cover story for the real conspiracy that
the living Nick Fury we've seen over
these past couple years is actually his
scroll duplicate carrying on his mission
and that would give new meaning to the
moment fury reveals himself to Alexander
Pierce but if you want to stay ahead of
me mr. secretary
you need to keep both eyes by both eyes
scroll Fury could be referring to both
Furies each one with one eye open and
this girl fury is furious with Pierce
for killing the original eye in my
breakdown of Captain Marvel I explained
how Fury's lie about how he lost his eye
he said a Kree did it not Goose the cat
slash lurkin and Fury's decision to keep
it covered with an eyepatch instead of a
prosthetic eye could be a subtle move to
defend himself from any potential scroll
and posture like if he keeps his eye
covered no scroll wouldn't know from
sight alone what the real wounded eye
underneath looked like this eyepatch
would have been Fury's one security
check against his Skrull twin so if this
theory is true he would have had to show
his eye wound to the scroll in his dying
moments pour that scroll to be able to
read his face and be able to copy it
later and who was the closest to Fury in
that moment of his death that's right
dr. Joe Russo this squirrel surgeon
episode 8 just a case for why and a fury
could be a scroll it's also a case
against Joe Russo himself I'm onto you
yourself now there is even more evidence
of Fury's scroll spear see but before I
continue thank you to manscape for
sponsoring this video
you know how keeping things neat and
tidy downstairs can feel a bit like Thor
getting a haircut on Sekar plus it turns
out that you should not use the same
razor to trim your beard that used to
trim other places just kidding I knew
that I promised manscape comm is the
only men's brand dedicated to below the
waist grooming and hygiene with tools
created by a team of aerospace engineers
we're actually featured on shark tank
this is the lawn mower 2.0 it's a water
proof trimmer with a powerful 6,000 rpm
motor it has a replaceable ceramic blade
head with skin-safe technology meaning
that you won't get Nick Turse snagged or
totally castrated it's a real concern
with a lot of guys hairy guys manscape
comm lets you get a replacement blade
delivered every three months to ensure
the trimmer stays identic in this
perfect package 2.0 manscaping kit also
comes with crop preserver moisturizing
deodorant crop Reviver spray crop
cleaner shower gel refined cologne and
magic mat disposable shaving mats with
comic so you can read this is pretty
brilliant like if Marvel would print
their comics on shaving mats
my nuts would look like a golf course
you should good manscaped a shot it's
risk free there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee and here's a free gift for new
rock star subscribers the Shedd travel
bag you can get 20% off plus free
shipping plus this free gift with the
code rock stars 20 at manscaped comm ok
back to this next piece of evidence a
loose end from Avengers age of Ultron
clue number 4 fury covered up a UFO this
is when Fury and Black Widow we're
looking for the Hulk who disappeared
from sokovia and the Quinn jet one of
our tech boys flagged this splashed down
in the Banda sea
could be the Quinjet but with Starks
stealth tech we still can't check the
damn thing probably jumped out and swam
to Fiji so the odd thing is banner in
the Quinjet didn't land in the pond to
see near Indonesia they ended up once a
car the trash planet and thor ragnarok
so what was the unidentified object that
fury was referring to it could be a lot
of things but one of the implications
that I really liked from Captain Marvel
is that UFO sightings of the 80s and 90s
might have been Skrull related like
remember Talos his family and other
scroll refugees were hidden on Marvel's
lab cloaked invisibility in Earth's
orbit but they still got to eat they
must have made trips down to the surface
for food another toys for the kids
probably leading some loon spotting them
and telling Mulder and Scully about it
now bow scroll left at the end of
Captain Marvel
but if scroll slash fury was left alone
on earth he could have been making
contact with other scroll visitors over
the years look we don't have proof that
Fury was doing that but we do know fury
spotted some UFO and never brought it up
again but when you watch Captain Marvel
again there's one more possible clue
when Nick Fury gets to know Carole and
Pancho's bar he tells her his full name
Nicholas Joseph fury saying everyone
only ever calls him fury in fact a few
scenes later in the elevator
Talos calls fury Nicholas which is what
tips off fury that his boss is actually
a scroll in disguise
the fact that this red flag shoots up
upon hearing his first name is
interesting because later clue number 5
fury goes by Nick and doesn't react and
the post-credits scene after Avengers
infinity war notice the interaction with
Maria hill multiple bogies
saying energy signature of New York ten
times bigger Oakland
uh-huh how many Knicks was that three
mix now maybe fury doesn't react because
there's obviously bigger fish to fry in
this moment or maybe this means he'll is
a scroll like Talos was or maybe the
fury in the 90s who once hated being
called his first name died in Winter
Soldier and has ever since before
replaced by a scroll imposter who
doesn't mind Nick her Nicholas or Nicky
one bit not just taking down the
carrier's name we're taking down sheet
now I can hear some of you in the
comments shouting another possible clue
at me the toast the toes yes you're
referring to the detail that fury told
Carol about that no one else knew about
him that he cannot eat toast if it's
sliced diagonally after Captain Marvel
came out some genius entertainment
blogger got all horny because there's a
scene in age of Ultron and which fury
makes a sandwich and dozens of idiots
started posting headlines claiming fury
cut that sandwich diagonally but I got a
debunk this you're all wrong
not only is fury not eating a sandwich
or even toast he's just eating raw
sliced bread like a weirdo if you
actually look at this footage the
shading and visible services on that
piece of bread clearly indicate four
sides of a rectangle meaning it was
sliced horizontally or vertically not
diagonally you get sorry it so worked up
but when you play in the big leagues of
Avengers breakdowns you better be
prepared look at this frame by forked
breeze so yes while this sliced bread
detail isn't really the greatest
bombshell since sliced bread there
remains several other unusual
inconsistencies in the Cure's backstory
that make him a prime candidate of the
secret scroll in this scroll search what
other Marvel characters should we look
at next in our scroll search comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on instagram and on twitter at a vas and
subscribe to new rock stars for all of
our Avengers theories and if you live in
the LA area come check out my live
comedy show darkest timeline where I
join hilarious nerds I think Nick Fury
is gonna show up in a night of
pop-culture obsession it's every first
Friday of the month including my
upcoming birthday show on April 5th Acme
theatre North Hollywood ticket info in
the description below thank you for
watching and let's hope this scroll
search wraps up soon because the scroll
no loose it's a real problem we could
all end up getting scroll tits girl to
us my
for the name of the series I know it's
pretty inappropriate
[Music]